does that feel pearl
um
i don't think that men and women should
be paid the same in sports because they
don't put on like they don't make as
much money
so i i play volleyball and basketball in
europe and it it's unfortunate because
there's really not a lot of opportunity
in women's sports but i don't know how
you can complain when men make more
money at those sports so if you're a
business and one business brings in more
money
and one business brings in less money of
course you're gonna br pay the business
that make the players
for the business that makes more money
more it's just common sense like they're
not
you don't see
male only fans models complaining
because they don't make the same as
their female counterparts but ali equal
pay for equal work isn't this is this
it's not equal work because it's about
the revenue so it's about how much money
are you bringing in like who watches
women's basketball here i don't watch
anything yeah okay are you sports guy
huge sports guys
yeah okay and you watch men's basketball
right all the time i i'm a female
athlete i'm i'm probably top like one
percent in terms of talent and how far
i've like taken well i mean when you
come count like people because you're
tall you're six four i'm six foot like i
have the opportunity to play pro next
year not a lot of people get get to do
that right and i can tell you that i
even in basketball which i play
i don't want to watch women's basketball
why is that even though you play it
because they're not they're not as good
and i mean that's not fun i i genuinely
my heart of soul like i'll probably turn
down that contract because it just isn't
enough money how much do you think the
contract will be the contract well i
could go to a terrible country like a
country where like no one lives it's
like this island in like iceland or
something okay and make like three four
grand a month not bad right free housing
but
i'd be living like in the middle of
nowhere or i could go to germany and get
like 500 a thousand a month and i have
nothing yeah and i have friends that
were like top 20 in the ncaas like they
played on those teams for volleyball and
like
they they might make 70 which which is
decent but
when you think they're in the top like
half
0.25 percent skill-wise that's like
nothing
so is this um ali for you is this
equality for the sake of equality did
these women earn that
no i don't think they earned it this is
why i think feminism is a female
supremacy movement i'm just keeping it
honest so there are just some horrible
facts of life if you choose to look at
them as awful it can also be a benefit
to be physically a woman that's my
perspective on it but the reality is is
that men are
faster they're stronger they can make
faster plays on the field where when you
watch female sports they're sluggish
they just move slower that's my that's
my perspective on it so they basically
wind enough to convince somebody to pay
them the same as men even though they're
not turning the same profit and then
what's the trickle-down effects of this
what what's the next area where women
are going to demand equal pay that takes
a sharp turn into communism and
redistribution of wealth i think it's
dangerous well and and you don't know
what that's going to do to the business
as a whole if you're like you you you
own a business right and you know if
you're paying your employees too much
and you can't keep up like you're not
making enough money to pay them like
that hurts everybody
so like why
instead of instead of whining about
equal pay why don't we work on putting
on a better show so you think coco do
you think you think that you the u.s
soccer federation doesn't have money so
that's why like they should not give
them to the women i think there's enough
money to go around then why then why
wouldn't they give it to them they're
giving it right now aren't they but
why do they have to want like you don't
okay so you can't accept you're not
going to accept an offer that you're not
worth
so if they didn't if they weren't cool
with getting paid that much they
shouldn't have accepted the initial
offer
and so like now now you're going to see
them like gassing up the price even
though i'm sure like the revenue
hasn't gone up go ahead do you think
they deserve this oh good for them okay
well it doesn't hurt me yeah let me let
me just i'm not a huge soccer fan but i
can tell you this i watched like male
soccer in europe yeah
the uh let me just tell me if this
changes your guys perspective at all
the u.s
women's soccer team what are they doing
in that picture
they win a championship they won they're
actually winners right the men's team
freaking sucks sorry male soccer team so
because they won should they get paid
more well or is it just revenues the
bottom line yeah it should be based on
like i don't know the numbers behind
right so if this was a situation where
they really were bringing in more money
and they're demanding a raise fine fine
but what happens more often than not
even if it's a losing men's team they
tend to make more than a woman's team
and i'm a female athlete i spent most of
my life playing sports like i i really
care about women's sports but i can't
whine and cry because more people
attended the men's basketball games in
college than ours like it just is what
it is and we can either work to improve
the sport as a whole or we can whine
about our pay and i'm just tired of
these girls whining about their pay
instead of like focus on your sport get
better
go ahead you know they got beat by a
high school uh high school soccer team
the men's the women's team got beat by a
men's soccer team yes men's high school
yes that's that's actually something
that occurred so they're gonna get this
equal pay with these male athletes that
are you know top tier but they can't
even compete with high schoolers
so like i don't think they earned it
so
you're bringing up valid points here
do you ever like i assume you're going
to start running into women that are
going to start yelling at you pretty
soon i don't think she cares about that
at all
we already do
really
what are those interactions like go to
the dirtiest dirtiest weirdest most
salacious comment what do you get i had
someone tell me that they were going to
do witchcraft on me and my future babies
so that was a lot who was that person i
don't need her name but like why did she
say this what is she about
i don't know i think she got triggered
by me take talk i mean whoever reads the
comment every video is gonna have some
like if you post a puppy video
somebody's gonna say look at this [ __ ]
that [ __ ] this woman was special this
woman was special she was like calling
me on instagram and like trying to get
her girlfriend to call me too but
obviously there's these are low value
women that coco doesn't associate with
you know what i mean so
yeah the weirdest thing out there i
think i had somebody send a letter to my
school once too a letter to your school
i didn't even know that yeah somebody
googled my school and sent me a letter i
mean it was it was a creep though
i was i was in college i just graduated
um all right wrapping this thing up
natalia we're gonna take some questions
now and then after the questions
everyone will get their last two cents
and we'll wrap this thing up this has
been great okay okay i'm having a lot of
fun you're natalia do we have some super
chats
yes you want so some of them are just
comments you may just read the question
ones
if there's some strong comments throw it
out there to the atmosphere let it out
there but we would like to answer some
questions go ahead so i'll start with a
question this is from donovan sharp 20.
you know donovan nice
hello donovan um it's for coco
and it says what do you offer your
boyfriend that you've never given to any
other man be specific please don't use
answers like it depends or i'm not i
don't have the liberty to say please
answer the question what do you offer
what do i offer to my boyfriend that you
haven't offered to any other boyfriend
my wisdom is a 31 year old
i was never 31 before okay
so your man's getting your wisdom all
right um go ahead natalia keep going
let's see it says the soccer deal this
is from blue pill unplugged five dollars
it says the soccer deal demonstration uh
demonstrates once again that men enable
women to being able to enjoy unequal
outcome but women will still trash talk
to men
so that was a comment okay um and then
this one is from jg five dollars he says
what does coco's boyfriend do for work
does she fear he's just stringing her
along play how playing house um why
hasn't he married yet
i'm not gonna say what he does for work
but my my goal is not to put him in a
he's not a public person so like